these days you can 3d print plastic at
the local copy store plastics are easy
to process they are flexible and melts
at relatively low temperatures but
plastics are much weaker materials when
compared to metals or ceramics ceramics
have a lot of desirable properties
they're highly heat resistant and strong
for example they've been used to shield
shuttles during reentry
however being heat resistant and brittle
means it's not easy to make ceramics
into complex shapes it also makes it
hard to 3d print them enter polymer
derived ceramics these materials start
out as a polymer and through a heating
process are converted into a ceramic now
we are set for 3d printing first the
polymer is shot with a laser this UV
light causes polymerization
wherever the mask is not present giving
the emerging solid a complex shape then
the printed polymer is baked at 1,000
degrees while exposed to argon gas these
3d printed ceramics have 10 times the
compressive strength of commercially
available materials and survive
temperatures up to 1700 degrees Celsius